long day huh a little bit long weekend
you show up this morning
to put on seven
four down
I'm interested in a little bit of your
mindset
walking up knowing your four down and 29
holes to play
I mean I
to be honest I wasn't really thinking
that much about it
about the deficit right I know it was a
possible two-shot swing very good odds
of being a one shot swing so I was like
I'm gonna start off the right way
make my pod regardless of what Brooks us
and then move on with my round and try
to make some birdies out there and
started great and then stumbled a little
bit at the end but it wasn't plain easy
whatsoever
the goal was accomplished I
I reduced the deficit to half which is
great
and I had 18 holes to play with with
Brooks himself and try to beat him there
wasn't
I wasn't thinking too much about it
directly right I was just basically
worried at what I could do how does that
generally work in terms of you got to
focus on your game I get that there's no
time almost to consider the situation
but if you don't consider the situation
you may end up in trouble well
we're talking about a golf course where
the margin of error is very small right
so you got to do you got to do you no
matter what's going on basically uh I
have to expect that Brooks is going to
hit the best shot he can possibly hit at
that moment
and that's it I'm gonna do what I need
to do
um
I think the most important thing was
commitment to the shots I was picking
and commitment to the swing commitment
to the number right and even if I was
taking a more conservative route
conservative
still be aggressive I still have the
mindset of playing good golf and making
birdies and that's what I carried all
day when you started on Thursday with
the double bogey
is it really not in your head at all is
it how could it not be
very simple tee shot great swing second
shot great swing low wind gust
the first putt everything great but the
light but the speed second putt
everything great by the line
third putt everything great but the read
it really the funny thing is all those
putts felt good right
there was this one little small detail
wrong with each one of them and that's
why I missed them but
uh I kind of laughed right I laughed I
was upset for a second yes but I told
Adam right away I was very positive
about it all of them felt good we have
71 holes and then I remember a quote
from Savi himself right when he was
asked how can play around your level
four putt right I miss I miss I miss I
make and then you move on uh the birdie
pattern two was key and then following
it up on three even part through three
holes it's
I'll take it right so it really I turned
it around very quickly so as I mentioned
we work for sort of a general news
program and I think a lot of people be
getting a little bit more insight into
your journey
did you really not speak a word of
English 12 years ago when you arrived no
that is
a very big lie
I spoke English maybe not not the best
of levels
uh my understanding of the language was
better than what people thought it's
just
it's different from speaking one hour in
your classroom or two hours a day to
live in in a different language
the main difference as well was we learn
UK English UK slang
and I came to the U.S so things are a
little bit different right so there was
a period of adaptation right and at
first you know when you just asked me
that question I would have to translate
everything to Spanish understand it
think what I wanted to say in Spanish
and then translate it to English that
depending on what
the question was can be a very long
process so a lot of times a lot of
people are going to film in this we've
been in this situation I would just say
yes or no out of sphere just nervousness
and shyness and a lot of times he
misunderstood right
um so yeah at first they struggled a
little bit but
a month or two months in things started
to get a little bit better my brain got
a little bit quicker I had the
Translating part and eventually
you know there was no thought into it
right was there American television or
music that helped you along the way
couple things I did watch
I had a couple seats of of How I Met
Your Mother downloaded and I kept
watching them over and over with English
subtitles and Spanish subtitles because
it helps right always in English but
subtitles were different sometimes and
then
I know you're alluding to it a lot of
people mention it
uh because of a teammate of mine who
memorized basically every rap song that
at that point was in top 100
uh because I thought it was so cool how
he could just
vocalize it so quickly uh took it up on
myself to to learn a song and at that
point uh Kendrick Lamar had just dropped
his second studio album which was a good
kid Mad City
and there's a song called Backseat
Freestyle freestyle that
uh we just when he came he started
listening to it and uh we started
memorizing it and
I did had no idea what I was saying not
a clue obviously I knew what words I
could say and couldn't say but I had no
idea what I was saying never understood
it but the Seer exercise
of having to say those words that fast
it ended up being a vocal exercise that
helped me keep up with the conversation
quite a bit quicker it was not only one
song I started doing it with every song
that was popular at the time and you
knew where Compton was exactly last
question for you
um because I know that you have
plenty of ambition
as we're sitting here now
is this reality meeting your dreams or
is this reality exceeding your dreams
thanks Sadie
uh honestly
you can't
you can't wrap your head around with
this evening is
right through
starting the way that they started to
walking down an 18 with a four shot lead
making that up and down for par the
Ovation the feel on that Ovation and
then being with my family seeing my dad
who almost didn't didn't come
um
to see an Ali that was probably the most
emotional part of the day seeing him and
seeing history of the game alive for me
to everything that comes
with the ceremony of the green jacket
and everything afterwards right so I
don't think anybody can possibly
understand what it is unless you live
through it so yeah I would say it
exceeds